it might be easy to forget that xena
warrior princess was a spin-off
originally appearing as a secondary
character in hercules legendary journeys
xena launched her own show and blew past
hercules in popularity eventually
becoming a wild rating success
starring kevin sorbo
michael hurst
and for the first time ever lucy lawless
as xena warrior princess in fact xeno
roya princess was so popular the
spin-off series actually almost spawned
its own spin-off series called amazon
high sadly though it never aired why the
clues can be found in season 5 of xeno
warrior princess which featured one very
unusual episode and that's saying
something considering that zena season 5
mostly focused on an evil baby and zena
slaughter of all the olympian gods but
lifeblood episode 16 stands out because
it includes a time travelling selma
blair lifeblood recycled footage from
the two hour and aired pilot of amazon
high starring blair which would have
been a spin-off from xena blair played
cyan a modern girl of 1998 who by way of
a magic dagger is transported into
caveman times centuries before even the
story of zena takes place in amazon high
cyan is considered the chosen one in the
tribe of female warriors cyan buts heads
with samsara played by zena regular
danielle cormac and becomes friends with
a girl who can communicate with animals
she's then captured by a tribe of
cannibals led by core played by another
xena regular future film star carl urban
cyan later befriends core domesticates
horses and names her new tribe of
warrior women amazons so why didn't
amazon high work out the show's main
writer rob tappert had a pretty
impressive hit rate tapered created xena
then moved on to other syndicated shows
like cleopatra 25 25 and young hercules
amazon high seems like a sure thing
right well it should have been
syndicated shows were big business in
the early 90s baywatch proved that such
shows could be financially profitable
and according to the la times xena and
his predecessor hercules actually
outperformed baywatch at one point it
would make sense to try and get another
show out of the swords and sandals
franchise the problem for tapper was
that the success of xena and hercules
spawned a lot of imitators tapper told
the website to book of the dead that he
decided to axe amazon high at the very
moment they signed a deal to make the
show saying everybody was pleased with
what they bought and i was standing at
the monitor watching the lost world
promo and i said you know what we've
been ripped off so many times we have to
do something fresh around this time
there were similar shows on the air
about tarzan sinbad and conan the
barbarian tapat told the la times the
baywatch people are doing simbad and of
course there are a bunch of other
ripoffs on the way i mean what are we
going to do young moses freedom fighter
so tapper took the basic 90s woman time
travels back to a more savage time plot
and flipped it creating cleopatra 25 25
a show about a modern exotic dancer
traveling forward in time and fighting
the robots that have taken over the
earth it was an early breakout role for
firefly star gina torres while we'll
never know how things would have turned
out for amazon high tappers may have had
the right idea about needless imitators
flooding the market with copycat shows
but at least we got xena
from this moment
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]